so you mentioned that you entered
philanthropy because you felt a
responsibility how would you recommend
engaging potential donors who don't feel
that responsibility hmm that's a tough
one I think that that some people really
feel that you know it's either not there
it's not their responsibility or also
something that I hear a lot is well no
no no I need to make my money now and
then i'll i'll give it away once i once
once we take the tech company public you
know and I guess I think maybe a good
way to engage those kind of reluctant
potential donors is storytelling you
know if you can if you can engage them
with an individual that whose life could
be changed because they did decide to
feel responsible or they did decide to
be empathetic I think I found that to be
the most effective appeal bringing it to
a one on one level sometimes people get
really overwhelmed by big statistics and
you know when they say well great so my
you know my $5,000 is going to be a drop
in the bucket I'm not going to solve sex
trafficking but you know bring it down
to almost like the starfish metaphor
right it was like well you saved that
one starfish so yeah so do you think it
really is a moral responsibility that
they're ignoring or are they correct in
saying that they can choose to not have
that responsibility or to not feel that
responsibility I believe it is there
there I think it's a moral imperative
personally um because you know we are we
are a community of people we need to
help each other you don't you know if
you're alone on an island you will die
and so um I think that that it's just
completely against every human instinct
to deny helping somebody else I mean
what do you think that it's
some extent it's a moral responsibility
or do you think it's a choice you know I
don't know I I study moral philosophy a
bit and there's this question of whether
there is an objective morality or not
and I don't have the answer to that yet
um i doubt that i will but it's it's a
good question